this is a production of Cornell
University
the library's liaison to cooperative
extension so I do a lot of work with
extension educators around the state
basically trying to help them find the
information they need to do their jobs
one of them and what I think I might do
just briefly is just show you an online
guide that I've created it's sort of a i
think it's i think i still call it a
portal but the term portal is like it
sounds like 1995 or something I mean
it's a little but the idea is that it's
a it's an online resource that's easy to
get to that sort of collects together a
lot of the resources that are available
to extension folks through through
Cornell and through the library and
through me so I think what I might try
to do is share my screen just to show
that briefly give you a kind of a quick
overview of it and then I'll just open
it up to questions and conversation so
here's here's the here's the portal
which is pretty easy to find it's just
the URL is up here guys that library at
cornell edu underscore cce / cce
underscore portal you can also do
Cornell Cooperative Extension man
library and I think it will play just
google it and it'll come up but and I
won't go into too much detail here some
of you actually may have be familiar
with this already but what I tried to do
here is collect all the resources and
services that extension staff have
access to both the online resources
which you know I think most everyone in
corporate extension unless you really
knew you understand that you are
considered a full Cornell staff member
in terms of access to the Cornell
resources so there are a lot of
recollection acree sources that we
Cornell provide pays the subscription to
it and you can get access to if you
our current Cornell faculty staff or
students so that includes all
cooperative extension staff members with
a net ID so just again it kind of goes
through what you can do in terms of
finding books and journals a lot of this
a lot of these resources are available
online the other thing to remember for
what it's worth is if you search the
Cornell library online catalog and find
books that are in print we still have a
lot of really high quality resources
that are available in print if you find
those using our catalog and they're here
at man library you can actually order
those and have them delivered through
the mail for free so it's not just the
electronic resources but their actual
the print resources the books that we
have if you need that and you you know
it's not readily available in your local
library that is an option and so I think
that is over viewed the it there's
further explanation in the document
delivery section right here there's a
link here under library services so i
won't go into too much detail about that
and the final section of in there you
know there's a lot of information here
so when you have some time just go
through it i think and ultimately let me
go switch back here so kind of going
back and forth this link my picture here
with my link actually if you click on it
you can send me an email so i think if
all else fails or even from the
beginning you're like i just need help
finding information for this grant i'm
putting together or this you know this
program i'm putting together or I need
to do evidence-based programming that
seems to be a big one send me an email
and i'll i'll either know the resource
or the answer or I'll be able to help
you find it and I'm going to so that's
just on the first page here it's jpk 15
it's not some great secret or anything
and then under tutorials here at the
very end this is where I put together
this top ten things every cooperative
extension staff member should know about
the library and this is something I do
in person for
new extension staff when they come those
who come to campus I'll do this in
person and kind of go through it I think
for the interest of time I won't what I
will tell you is that each one of these
is a link to a variety of resources that
I these are everything you have
available obviously you know it's just a
scratching the surface but I think
there's some of the the more important
ones to know from the beginning
including my email right there I've also
put some guides here which can be useful
very specifically focused guide some of
them I've created some of them my
colleagues have created one of them is
this finding funding and this seems to
be in terms of the training the webinars
the outreach I've done to cooperative
extension staff in the last couple of
years the funding piece not surprisingly
seems to be one of great interest and so
I'll just click on this link here and
I've just recently let me see if this so
I've recently just updated this to
include crowd funding sources of
information which is a relatively new
phenomena but it's a way of basically
passing the Hat virtually online and
there the Cornell library has some
electronic books that you don't have to
check them out you don't have to order
them from the library you can actually
just log on and read crowd funding for
dummies so that's another source
traditionally I focused on New York
State US federal and private
philanthropic sources of funding and I
do webinars on the foundation directory
which is the primary index to private
and corporate funders the ones with you
know you think gates you think
Rockefeller those the big funding the
big sources of me and actually the
smaller local foundations which can have
money as well so the foundation
directory is the most important source
for that sort of information
and so that link is there that's a
subscription database so it's not freely
available you everyone in Cooperative
Extension does have access to it it's
it's not that hard to learn and then
there's some online tutorials and
actually I think we owe ya in 2012 I
think I gave one of these webinars and I
recorded it so it's like 30 minutes and
I walk through it I can't guarantee that
it's the most professionally done thing
but it gives you the basic sense of what
it does and of course if you start to
use it and have questions let me know
Jim hi this is jen i was i was in a i
think of program program leadership
development cohort than you did you did
you kind of did a sit-down with us and
helped us look through the foundations
during yeah and set up those are it does
yep yeah because I think that a lot of
us are now spending a good chunk of time
either searching for funding writing
grants or administering that those
grants so I think I don't my self that a
little bit less time now on programming
a little more time on finding funding at
but then you brought up a great a great
point is that now as we are engaging in
this funding it is really important to
be able to find things like
evidence-based practices and that kind
of support material for the grant
writing that you're doing so I don't
even know where to begin with that right
all right I know it's you know you need
the you need the grant funding to do the
programming and then you need to be able
to have you know a plan with evidence of
your program to get the fun so it's it's
almost this catch-22 you know like where
do you start you look for the and you
have to deal with in both yeah I yeah
absolutely and I think that the
foundation directory and those other
sources are really great to know about
they exist and you know in terms of
doing the evidence-based and finding the
evidence
I certainly can I can help folks with
that as well it's not easy i mean the
research I tried to tell Coronel
undergraduates this and you know I'm not
sure it might go in one ear and out the
other but the research process takes
time to do it well to actually find
things it gets better the more you do it
but I'm doing finding that evidence can
it's not just like you type it into
Google and you know the top three hits
are exactly what you need to to I am
right support what you're doing but it
does get easier and I can certainly help
with that process and maybe save you
some time to okay I think that I think
and also since we are working along you
know within our mission within our
priority areas that sometimes you start
to build a kind of system of knowledge
or a bunch of ideas of practices and be
able to follow those down there you know
to try to build a am I trying to say
almost a library of ideas that you have
now drawing from for for grant funding
and writing writing those grants so yeah
I mean I think it's there is a there is
an opportunity and a challenge here to
tap into the collective experience of
all the cooperative extension educators
across the state or even beyond you know
about how is it you successfully go
about in terms of specifically in terms
of the funding how is it that you do
that you know and sometimes you can one
of the things you can do and I think I
probably showed you guys this for your
leadership court you can go into the
foundation directory and find what other
you know other County Cooperative
Extension agencies what what grants
they've gotten and for what so you know
but there is this there is a possibility
for this collective like you Cosette a
library of knowledge about how how to do
this well or even relevant you know
papers that really speak
what we do and because there's so many
you write much out there right how do
you find you know right it's a right now
it's a huge thing and they're actually
there now it's so important I know here
at Cornell I mean I'm not really
knowledgeable about the whole the
scholarship behind like evidence-based
methodologies but they're now offering I
think in the College of human ecology
they're offering a minor in
evidence-based research so it's you know
it's like oh wow so it's you know it's
something that is obviously being you
know it's being considered really more
seriously at that level well we have
recently had kind of funding questions
from partners we work with and they're
coming down kind of above from their
funders saying we know we don't really
want to follow through with this project
if there isn't an evidence-based
practice and they're not just talking
about something that was just research
they are looking for something kind of
like a cookie cutter program that has
been instituted somewhere has got good
research behind it and good evidence
that it worked you know that kind of
yeah yeah yeah yeah that right right
right right with a different meaning
than evidence-based that oh i thought
you know so yeah that is that is really
interesting and the other thing I again
i'm i'm outside the loop on this but it
also just seems that what works for in
terms of an evident but evidence-based
programming for of say a 4-h program in
utah isn't necessarily going to work for
the same 4-h program in onondaga county
in new york I mean I just even there's
all manner the notion of a cookie cutter
and up when it's it's it's an ambitious
idea yeah and then conversely it's kind
of throw the baby out with the bathwater
if you have a promising practice
something that looks like hey you know
there's a lot of good research behind
these ideas let's try it out but because
it doesn't have
some evidence-based template to follow
it's like up right now that's not good
yeah exactly i mean i do this all the
time with my with my teaching that i
work with faculty in the two colleges
cals and human ecology you know and it's
like we're being asked the library and
the librarians are being asked to do
more assessment of what we do you know
to actually assess how effective they
are and for me when the faculty member
says if I talk to the faculty member
after the class and they say you know
that's great that really worked well I
mean I think I can see the stew it was
really useful to students for me that's
that's a really very that's a primary
piece of assessment of what I did it
doesn't that's not a rubric it doesn't
it's not something I can put in Excel
and show somebody and say eighty-five
percent of the students who took my
workshop did you know seventy
significantly better on their final exam
that's not the level you know but for me
that more qualitative assessment of the
of the word of mouth from the faculty
member is all I need thankfully my
funding is not based on needing to get
those numbers but I think and a lot of
time but if people are giving you money
they want the numbers they do they want
to be able to report back and say right
and say okay so everybody can check off
their little box yes it's that's a
strange yeah yeah not necessarily useful
it might understand where it has to do
but in the real world that that's right
getting right getting to people is what
we're after right right if other people
are also spending time gathering
research to support their work you know
is there a way we can I share that in a
and some forum or is it already being
done no no there could be right there
you know what I and and the sharing what
you're basically doing is sharing
published research on the on this topic
you know basically
journal articles is that what key
research findings is that the yep so
that will be that will be okay so what
yeah what I would recommend and I've
worked with a number of other either lab
groups or groups on campus to do this
what you can do is you can start and if
you had a group you don't even have to
be in the same office you're on an app
you can do this online there's a there's
a program called Zotero it's a free
online program zo te R 0 0 RG and I can
I can pull let me actually see let me
see if I can show you an example Cornell
what's the do well actually there's one
there's oh not survey researchers that's
a funny system of rice intensification
okay so this is this is through see fad
and international programs but what they
actually have done is and I've helped
them do this they put together this
online database of research so this is a
not to get in too much detail but the
system of rice intensification is a as a
system of increasing the yields of rice
it's fairly controversial and one of the
things this group wanted to do was show
the evidence speaking of evidence from
published research on the effectiveness
of this system of growing rice called SR
I or system of rice intensification so
what they did and I'll actually just do
search for rice because so this is
Zotero and what they've done is they've
put together this online library that
and there are probably two or three
people in the group cooler
administrators who oversee this and add
material to the library and then it's
completely open to anybody in the world
and what it it's not the
world's greatest interface but it's very
logical that you know you can organize
these the library's organized into some
subfolders and then each one of these is
the link to an article depending on how
you want to do it you can include the
full text of the article as well and
there's no limit in terms of the number
of people who can be in this group so I
it it works it's a it takes a little bit
to learn the program but I think for the
kind of program you're talking about
this this could be a very effective
solution and I'd if you if you want to
explore it I'm happy to help you get
going with that
Thanks that is helpful and so is this a
good way if somebody's trying to
research a topic to sort of gather you
know their effort yeah exactly so what
you could do is if there are you know
what I possibly could imagine if there's
a core group of you in the in your group
who are doing the research on a
particular topic within your field I
mean you wanted to produce
collaboratively this database and share
it among yourselves and then also with
the general public that's exactly what
you could do so the program let me
actually open up hello so what you do is
you have the program on your individual
computer and I'll slide this over here
so it's a desktop program let me slide
this over here and you work on your own
computer and you would do your research
in whatever database you like so this is
my dusty this is my desktop version of
Zotero and I've got these folders here
and if I scroll down here when I get
into this section here these are the
group library so I can the other nice
thing about this is i can have my
individual research that I collect here
this is only for me and then under here
i got these group libraries that you
could share so if they are saved four or
five or six TV there's no limit on the
number but if there were four of you who
wanted to create a group library you
could have I could add I could do my own
research on this you know here's the
group on bees and if I did my own
research and imported these references I
went and did it i would add them to the
library here and then the program you
can see this little arrow is circling
over here what it's doing is its syncing
with the cloud so what would happen is
the this B group online which is what
everyone could access would be a place
where people could then go and see the
results but so it works these group
libraries work very well for
collaboration between people and then
also share
that you can make it you can keep it
private if you wanted to and just share
it among your small group but it sounds
like you you might also want to make
this open to the public not that they
could add or edit it but they could see
it and they could download the program
it's you know it's actually very and you
don't need to have the program installed
or even know how it works to be able to
go in and see these see the results of
these you know this is again this is the
online version this is that this is the
desktop version so one of the questions
we often have is our gardening topic
area instead of go in all sorts of
directions is there are people who could
you know guide us on how to serve
organize oh you know we have one big
folder or do we is there a structural
way that that seems to work better than
others so in terms of the you're
collecting all the research yeah yeah
you know we could be in lots of
different field you know one you know we
would be suppose a comment monitors in
general as a common topic and then we
can go to the different area where as
Genma suggestion you know childhood
obesity and growing vegetables right so
yeah I was going to say I I can tell you
what the the program can do here so for
example in this Cornell conservation
agriculture this is actually the coronal
conservation agriculture is another
example of one of these working live
databases from a cow's program so they
create a master library called Cornell
conservation agriculture and then within
that they've created all these sub
folders that a and it can range on
anything and the you know and you can
you can actually so if i look at this
level if i highlight cornell
conservation agriculture i'm looking at
everything in the library which is
probably at this point thousands of
citations and then if i click on one of
these like if i click under cassava I'm
only looking at the citations that have
been stored in cassava you so you can
create all these subfolders and then you
can actually put a single a particular
citation so this is a journal article
right here this this reference could be
in more than one of these folders so you
could you could have as many of these
sub folders as you wanted to you know
I'm not everybody is tempted to have a
folder called miscellaneous which i
think is dangerous because it's like I
don't know where but let's put it in
miscellaneous in an interest in don't
think so anyway it the tools for
organizing it are there I'm not I would
love to be but I am NOT personally a
particularly organized person so I'm not
sure how that best work it's probably
something for your group to hash out how
this might how this might work but I
think Zotero in itself kind of gives you
the ability to at a certain level be to
be fairly organized about it and then
just to let me actually see so here is
the system of rice intensification again
I'm this is on my desktop what I'm
showing you right now this is the
desktop program but here's the master
folder and then here are all the
subfolders and everything's doing and
then if I go back here there's exactly
so this is this is the online view this
is sort of the shared view that everyone
sees this is exactly the same thing so
here's the master library and then here
are the subfolders that have everything
there and you know again you can choose
to make this include the full text of
the article if you do that you can't
make it for copyright reasons obviously
you can't make the folder of fully
public one you would need to make a
public view would not include the full
text so that's that's a small
concentration but oh but I a question
about that gym then would people be able
to like people who are in the fold
to be able to print those out or where
they just use them as a reference and
then go find ya know they could they
could you know if they wanted to if they
want to take these you know if you had
the Zotero program you could you could
join the group that's the other thing is
you could make it so that people could
join the group and download this into
their own folder but a lot of times
people are just there they don't want to
be bothered with that so you can see
here I'm pretty sure if I marked all
these records I could then export them
and here are different options let me
actually send that may not be the best
that's actually exporting it in a format
let me see if there is a way to I think
there should be just a way to to print
them out if you wanted to or you know or
email them to yourself I'll have to look
into that but there's definitely oh this
is interesting um no okay huh so you can
if nothing else if you wanted to you
could do this quick you could select a
style like APA style and then do a oops
if I did oh okay I could just copy them
all and paste them into my you know like
a word document like that but there has
to be an email function here somewhere
I'll have to look into that so yeah
people could print them out people could
email them they should be able to email
themselves and then go go and go and
find them if they're in the Cornell
network it's pretty easy to do it
sometimes that like in this case this is
a publicly available oh yes so they
could just huh well doesn't always work
or your plan yeah right URLs change but
a lot of this stuff is available right
through the for the man library yeah
absolutely yep yep so that's really cool
yeah
I could see that being helpful to a lot
of educators if that was essentially
it's kind of curated by our needs you
know we write and each other we figure
it out but then as we come across these
things they could get at it not that we
have another another moment of time to
do it right now but if you get them in
if you're doing this anyway yeah it will
actually save you a lot of time because
all you would then need to do is and the
nice thing is you can go into your
database of choice like scholar like if
I wanted to google scholar and I did you
know let me just out say community
gardening or something like that Anna
not be helpful if i spelled it right but
then the nice thing about the program is
so i'm in chrome on a windows-based
computer and I've got sottero installed
and there's this little folder here so I
click on this and then I could just grab
all of those citations and bring and
where they'll end up I'm not going to
bring them in right now but whether
they'll end up is in here so and then I
dumped them there and then it's so all I
need to do is go to my database do my
search these are probably things you're
doing already as part of your workflow
you know click the import which is just
clicking a button point it you can
either if you've got the folder
highlighted when you do the import it'll
just dump them right in there and then
when you when this thing sinks which you
will do automatically what so those
records I brought in from google scholar
will then end up in my online library
here automatically shared so you know if
you're just doing a lot of these things
anyway in terms of curating and
collecting their references it would
once you learn the program and get it
installed and figured out the
particularity of doing the shared
management of this you're not really I
don't you really not adding much in
terms of your workflow and then you're
saving in terms of the export and making
it publicly available and sharing it
you're saving all your time and not
having to do that part of it it's pretty
much automated well I turned it out to
the rest of you what do you think having
that kind of information like the garden
based learning page already has some and
we I think a lot of our us as educators
have tapped into those articles that are
referenced there but wood would having
something like this be helpful as we you
know a defend kind of what it is that we
do and when we talk to others about what
we do and then also as we're writing
writing grant proposals ? the other
thing I would say just and this is
definitely a conversation for all of you
to have among yourselves whether this
would be an effective tool you might
want to think about doing it on a very
small scale like create just like a
proof of concept for yourselves create a
small one like one folder with 20
references in it and put it up and see
what it see what it seems to does it
seem to work and does it seem like you
would want to put everything you're
doing into this database so you might
want to start in a very small part of it
the other and I sound a bit like an
infomercial except i'm not actually
selling anything the the thing you can
also do with the program which is really
nice so for like grant based programs is
once you get your references in here
then if you needed to or if in any
situation where you needed to share
these references so i'm just going to
take these particular ones here i go
create bibliography from items and i'll
just take a PA and then if I go into
uh so here's a blank Word document let
me slide this over here so I copied
those and then I just paste them in so
I've created you know on the really
quickly and you could have an annotated
bibliography want but anyway it's a list
of your sources that you could include
in an annual report or a grant project
or whatever you want so once the
information is in here it's really easy
to produce formatted lists of all or
some of those references so it's another
nice little part of the workings of the
tool and on a limited basis we could
just start with what we already have on
our garden based learning site and
change that from a list to this actual
format as it as they did on the other
website I I ya might not be that hard
it's really not i mean what again I
think what what I would encourage you to
do and I can help you guys do this if
you want to is take some of the I mean I
think the one that the thing that would
be the take the most time and it really
wouldn't be that much time and it's
certainly not particularly hard is to
take thee let me go back to your so if I
go back here and if I am if you're
putting together these lists of evidence
and i'm assuming down two summers you
have like a bibliography of these no
okay alright so i mean the other
pictures you can you okay so you could
create these could all be yeah if you're
putting these up anyway and you wanted
to make you know they look like they're
basically very well annotated citations
you could recreate that pretty easily
and that the thing to first do would be
to say you know you need to get this
article from Ratcliffe from the health
promotion practice a journal on here and
you know this is how this would be the
only thing that would take a little bit
of time as you would probably need to go
you could probably just do this so
there's there's this citation in Google
Scholar and I would just grab it and
bring it in and so you might need to go
a piece at a time and recreate your I
think yeah so that that would be the
thing that might take a little bit of
time but how because you how big is your
library right now I many you know 50 to
100 yeah I don't think it's that big but
what I think is happening is some
educators might be you know creating
their own little pile of references and
work out not effective tool to share
yeah and so if we have that tool like go
if you're doing something already you
know share it with the whole I'm sure
jen has done a lot of research related
to her pollinator project and you know
we don't have it in one place right yeah
so I feel like I am just too he's got a
lot in there too I can I was like trying
to look ojala call that stuff yeah I
know it's like a really easy to add it's
like they like oh my gosh and there's no
unlike like your your front hall closet
there's no shortage it's like was there
too many shoes in here it's just like
nope you just you don't run out of room
you just keep putting stuff in there
which can be a curse as well as a
blessing I guess right so I mean the
other thing too is if you've done all
that really it looks like you've done
great work with these annotations so you
could you could pretty easily copy these
so in addition to the like the basic
citation information that you would
import here even as their own feel you
could add you cadet exactly you could go
into Zotero
and put it on the cancellous you could
put in your own
so here here it actually is the article
let me get this a little more okay so
here's the article and then
so here's the citation over here and
then you could put it in like in the
abstract field
copy and paste it in there this would be
I'm could be a really good project for
like an intern yeah that's what I'm
thinking and just and then you would
just use a style on your website that
would have that would include the
abstract in your it would kind of be
there it wouldn't flow as a narrative
like this does I mean that would be the
one thing obviously is I mean you know
this is a nice narrative flow to it this
would be more like citation abstract
citation abstract but you know people
can look at that I suppose tell me so if
you guys want to I know talk among
yourselves and see if that might want to
work I'm you know send me an email I'm
around and I'm happy to help you get
started it's it's not it's not
particularly hard there's a little bit
of a little bit of things to figure out
and I know everybody's really pressed
for time but I think if you're putting
these things together anyway especially
if you have this feeling that there
might be other people out there who are
also collecting this information you
could just add them if you wanted to if
you've trusted them you could add them
as editors to the the library and then
they could add to it or they could just
send you what they have and you could
add it as well so okay where we are kind
of experimenting with something along
those lines already in a small scale to
see if that would work because we are
all working on the same things and it's
crazy to keep reinventing the wheel yeah
and I know that initially there would be
that big time output you know outlay but
then in time it would become more and
more efficient and hopefully would see
that on the back end when those
resources are all gathered for us right
right and the other nice thing too is if
you're putting this all like all these
list of references in a in a essentially
a database so if your if your website
changed you again you're just pointing
to this online site that's not going to
change so you could just
to it and yeah so thanks I think that
was really helpful sure to get us
organized on that on that level and
basically you know we're always eager to
find ways to make it easy for people to
explain why we are important right right
right that's an ongoing right you guys
know you're important but exactly one of
the things that we have which i think is
kind of its it is essentially a
credibility checklist I'm going to go
back and I'll just I'll show it to you
quickly and this everything i'm showing
you now is you know it's open it's an
open resource so you could either modify
it and adapt it to your own use or just
point people to it there's a section on
evaluating credibility which you know we
teach this undergraduate and it actually
it seems a little simplistic but it's
amazing how if you just tell people okay
so you pulled up a website can you
identify the author of this particular
article and what is these are her
credentials just by asking them to ask
themselves that question you realize
most of the time they don't even ask
that they don't even say well it's like
oh well it's a website is like well who
wrote this and if you can't find an
author that's probably a red flag and so
you kind of go through and the authority
the currency the purpose the bias the
accuracy of details and you can this is
kind of a a really kind of a mini thing
that you could you could put this
together in a little tip sheet and say
if you find a reference on the web just
do this five part checklist and see what
you can do if you wanted to go into more
detail UC Berkeley let me see I haven't
looked at this in a while see if the
link still works yeah their library goes
through this in like extensive detail so
this is sort of the the full full on way
to and this is usually for evaluating
credibility for web-based resources
it you know it's not really so much for
you found you were searching in a
database and you found a scholarly
article it's more like you googled the
topic and you came across this and it's
just a way you sort of keep it in the
back of your mind it's like what's the
authority what's the purpose what Wow
when was the spot is it is there a list
of references there is there a date it
was last updated those are so there's
little things there that that exists I
don't know if that helps but that's
that's there and you can feel free to
borrow as much or as little of this so
if you wanted to create a little tip
sheet for the public on this and you
included here's to your five questions
to ask in terms of credibility and then
you could add the tip that and I think
some people know this but a lot of
people don't which is that there is
there's an advanced Google search where
if you go into this you can actually so
it allows you to string your search
together a little bit better which is
helpful but the other thing too is you
can you can actually go and search by
specific domains so you know for example
if you are looking for compost if I look
for compost and just did a Google search
I'm probably going to get mostly sites
that want to sell me compost or
something like that but one of the
things you can do if I limited that too
just as an example if I limited compost
dot edu you're mostly going to get you
know in this case I'm getting either EPA
or Cornell Cooperative Extension sites
that or the University of Missouri so if
I if I limit it my search to an edu I'm
going to I'm going to filter out
immediately the commercial sites that
are self playing compost and you could
also you don't even have to send them to
the advanced search you could just say
you put in your search and at the end do
site colon edu if people get into the
habit of just instead of throwing the
net out in the lake and pulling back
whatever they find is like oh why don't
you throw out the net that will only
bring back dot o RG stuff or only edu
stuff with visual resources how to use
those resources in a way that makes you
safe and legal in terms of fair use and
those kind of things so that would and I
can this this is actually a subsection
of a guide oh here's yeah actually I
think this is actually quite useful this
is the one I was thinking of images a
guide to finding visual resources so
this is this is fully available public
anybody can get access to this and it
includes a section on copyright what is
fair use the other thing you can do in
terms of if you're a staff member if
you're actually a if your cornell
affiliated there's also if you have
specific questions so this this kind of
gives you the guide and you can walk
through this and it'll answer most of
your questions but if you had maybe a
more specific question and wanted some
guidance there is actually a there's a
visual resources working group within
the cornell library that will answer
that would be happy to work with any
cooperative extension staff members
those image databases we could freely
use from yeah exact i mean they're going
to tell you some of these are going to
be subscription databases and some of
them are going to be freely available
databases think there's subscription if
their subscription does cornell have the
subscription right exactly okay yep and
so an educator could could get access
they yes and so anything here cornell
specific or not like art store is a
database that you need to be affiliated
with cornell to get access to but they
have this whole section on open what
which these are all freely available
anybody can get access to them if you or
anybody else has any questions and then
specifically about setting up the Zotero
database when you if you think you guys
want to do that I'm happy to get you
started this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu